hey everybody you are watching gamespot
I'm here with one of my favorite people
marry Kish hello Alexa and we are
playing five nights at Freddy's 4 which
came out very unexpectedly before its
release date surprise now this is the
fourth Freddie's game in a year in less
than a year so he was supposed to
release the fourth one on august four
maybe yeah but he released it no no said
you know what it was ready um although
there's like some weird stuff already
with the game um like there's no exit
yeah there we cropped it but it's in
windowed mode and you can't um can't not
have any windowed mode of this dad you
can't full screen it yet which is weird
I think there's just like a few
technical weird things going on but it's
here but it is here you can see in the
lower right its version 1.0 I would not
be surprised if you saw a pattern coming
up yeah um so we're gonna play it I'm
gonna yeah I'm gonna start a new game or
just gonna go for it I am I do
anticipate some creepiness I can't
handle jumpscares I apologize in advance
oh here comes to the party five days
until the party so okay it looks like a
lot of the pieces from five nights at
freddy's 3 is cut are coming back yeah
mini games Oh what did he do this time
Oh locked you in your room so is that
supposed to be Freddy me golden Freddy
Freddy this is what this is me okay um
look at my berries like whoa creepy so
you have stuffed animals of all of the
uh animatronics yeah ones this thing
ahead is foxy missing a head or
something I'm just sayin they gonna
click to get out
yep and there's all I call our favorite
there's Bonnie and that's interesting
that they like have them oh my god
somebody's at the door no way can we let
them in mm-hmm I can't do anything right
now jun we can't do anything Wow oh this
is this is already whoa well this is
already very unnerving that's it I think
I lost um that'll look good night 10 all
right here we go oh my god all right
this looks like the real game Oh God
okay god this is what we expected um
let's see so click here to run to the
door okay listen carefully if you hear
breathing hold the door shut if you do
not hear breathing use your flashlight
flashlight is control and closing the
door is shift and then I go backwards
with my mouse so we have to monitor all
those doors and more importantly we need
to be which really sucks for us because
we're like talking a lot but like we
have to hear and if you hear breathing
I'm I'm not supposed to use my
flashlight okay and then I also have to
look behind me I saw that in the trailer
I remember that you look behind you in
the trailer it's 12 a.m. it should be
the same rules make it to six I don't
think I need these tips anymore get rid
of those good all right um so use will
have to listen and if you hear breathing
tell me breathing
okay um if you don't then I'll use the
flashlight okay dear them away which is
similar to like the previous games when
you need to use the flashlight use the
flashlight to kind of visually freak
them out okay I don't like it cuz I
really I'm like already not into this oh
my god even the things that aren't
supposed to be scarier scary that bears
horrible this phone sucks robots scary
typically the first night I find is
there a little kinder to you okay I
don't hear anything that running that
running um who's that I don't know I
hear it oh my god [ __ ] i shall check all
the doors two daughters all right all
right maybe the other door noises are
happening nothing yet they're just
messing with us they're doing a great
job I feel like crap the dread it's the
dread it's the dread it is there is no
fear in the shot of a gun only in the
anticipation of it oh you bastards show
yourself don't say that or make it to
six let it wrong yeah I think we're
gonna make it this is a really good door
that Creek is you yeah leaning out then
he knew I liked opening the door yeah
bed okay bed is good cod oh god wish it
was okay nothing good yeah but now is
when it gets worse yes 6am all right and
i'm sure there's new stuff going on in
this once i'm a little oh my god okay
four days until the party we've almost
made it to party okay here i am again
you know he's hiding again these are my
friends so who'd who's hiding okay i can
leave oh he won't stop until you find
him i wasn't able to leave before so he
won't stop until we find him who do we
need to find is it the kill okay like
the killer over there him the Freddie
man i'm stuck version there's another
another exit over there what the hell
what is that no there's no clicking is
that is that a face is this another
broken animal this was like a bedroom
dad look like good oh it's flowers as a
flowers no I don't know I can't tell
what that is our shouldn't look like
that but the law up the little sideways
face kind of looks like the mask on the
puppet tell me what to do you jerk
alright so I've seen o'clock a bedroom
and a TV room TV room is there anything
on the TV can we interact the TV that's
what it is oh that's right because the
Fox didn't have a head okay cod pixels
are [ __ ] terrifying anyway tomorrow's
another day oh god fun with plushtrap
hold ctrl to use the flashlight use the
trash light flashlight to stop plushtrap
on the x two skip two hours on the next
night ok I understand you know what that
means so you got that ok [ __ ] i saw this
in the trailer so okay so i need to stop
using the flashlight see and then he
might get off his chair but i had to
stop him
no I need you to count with me hi okay
one two three four five six oh my God
he's off he's off the chain one two
three four five six seven no it's
punishing to win why are their teeth on
all of these plushies Oh what's teen on
a stuffed animal sick sick person okay
all right all night too we're at 2am
because I won that mini game okay yeah
all right also oh my god go back all
right so let's get on her let's get on
it check the bed baby all right right
after this door all right we're doing
that get off ok feel like foxy never
really appears until later on I want to
communion check the closet so much you
know what I mean yeah the Fox he only
only in the closet normally you stay off
my damn bag off my bed um Oh heard
something there's something over there
all right so normally foxy was like the
wild card which I feel like it's the
same thing I hear everything nope all
right oh sorry I hit the thingy i should
have listed know it was a creek it was a
Greek but he's over there like there's
someone in that doorway here
I wasn't looking I didn't see it no he's
the flash like site plaza I couldn't
hear it the breathing like I didn't hear
it either what is it supposed to sound
like oh god you ain't came galavan all
right okay I'm really mad that that
doesn't carry over how do you know when
they go away do I just shut it for like
a really long time you know yeah get off
the bed yeah I feel like I'm a parent
got off the bag you know you can't be up
there hahaha got off that bread nothing
yet nothing yet it's only oh god it's
only midnight Oh mmm what I'm just
feeling it I'm just like so these are
internal things that you're dealing
internal feelings oh there's something
in there oh you [ __ ] what do I do you
just close the door right no no no so
like if I keep the light on do I keep
him at bay these are good questions ya
know is there another one yes you have
to use your eyes and your ears I'm just
listening we should probably close the
door it's alone he's walking by did you
hear it
I heard him walk by but I wouldn't oh I
hate both doors oh I saw him to say well
run between both doors maybe use your
flash I would not flash I heard a thump
you did your ears are better there's
something he's walking away so do not
flash don't just get out of there oh I
feel awful i did check the bed go check
the bed
Oh God forgot haha that was horrible
everyone's upset now gosh sure good
we're good okay left left flash I don't
hear anything oh okay so we're good no
no nothing's huh get it off my bed I
feel like once you get like four on
there you're dead bhaktya nothing this
is good all good all good stuff yeah
she's so [ __ ] bad I know I haven't
even dealt with closet issues yet that
he's used to scare me just by looking at
him now I hate them close it or I just
scared and walking around and [ __ ] I
can't tell
he walked by this is our brain no he
walked by your ears than I do can I open
it I guess Oh flash I don't hear
anything okay this is your job yeah well
I'm saying you are so good at this hey
here's yeah yeah you're you're better at
that than me I can't hear when they're
near me close or I heard something I say
you're the best I don't know I'm just I
lied maybe you're paranoid maybe nothing
nothing I gotta go those Freddie's or
yeah I used to lie awake in the dark at
night with the ghosts in the [ __ ] like I
was afraid of ghosts and monsters to
crop it I was little so I'm a pro at
this closer this can't be very
interesting like playthrough sorry guys
because we have to hear you
okay I heard thump thump thump thump
what the boy from door I don't know
she's in front on the other one I don't
hear anything okay good good weird let's
go what if he's at the other door John
Stehr been here I don't know like I
don't hear it like the breathing is so
quiet church oh I hear something out
there I think I heard something out
there closer I heard it I heard it that
time
i freakin heard it that our two thumbs
and I'm not hearing anything now I don't
know what that means I think he's gone
maybe I don't know what the thumps are
gone well at some point I have to
freakin move move get out of it sure
wait all right right dork check okay
okay okay we haven't checked the closet
in a while I think it's worth checking
oh I saw his eyeball I saw his eye so if
he's on the left whoa what happened
Carla Kim whoa I saw him okay he's on
the right door nothing uh-uh or anything
but he's rude if he's on the right door
okay let's go back to the right door
nothing we sure i'll check the bed okay
Joe left
I don't know sometimes you hear like
room noise yeah I hear something
I heard some something I did too but
it's not gone I think it's fine is that
what we're supposed to suit assume is
like the breathing damn it that scares
me 25 okay who's that I don't know okay
okay door
right door and son oh okay that was hard
oh my god okay this game is really
really low Earth Day party he left it
out you so this game is tough but not
not insurmountable if you run you can
make it where's the exit hurry run
towards the exit ready oz it to the
right it's too late hurry up the other
way and you will find someone who'll
help so this way sure oh my god i met
Freddie's there's a man in it though do
you see the eyes in you can find help if
you get past them you have to be strong
oh my god what the hell um oh my god
tomorrow is another day oh so we have to
we're trying to escape something oh this
again what was it six count of six kind
of 77 okay
wait okay okay you ready yep one two
three four five six son Oh waking Count
Olaf at one two three four five six
seven um 131 five six seven eight eight
so he's taking longer one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten ok 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 [ __ ] we're not going
oh my god I'm not gonna get the bonus
because she know it's changing each
nights that you can't just do it so it
was seven the first night but not that
one was probably like 13 me I'm 14
seconds yeah she's pretty punishing so
we made it tonight three we did I won't
like this game is insane it's just so
scary it's very audio-based is very
different um I think the other ones were
much more visual they were this one
requires a lot on listening so if you're
gonna play it play it with headphones um
thank you for watching old of closet oh
good god okay well uh we're gonna do
that thank you for watching mary i'm
glad i did this with you if i had to do
this with anyone we gonna come out come
out this way if he comes out won't just
end on a scare put your desk area you
know he's not a scary come yes you
[ __ ] do it just do it just come out
just do a con just do it or go back
inside all right I can't take this i can
today is so bad it's just the teeth I
can't with the teeth the teeth it's the
teeth please don't i don't want to make
this happen I don't wreck it happen well
here it is that's the game
in a nutshell thank you for watching
alright for more videos and video games
and all that cool stuff stay tuned to
gamespot com alright thanks guys bye
little terrified